for one weekend the fashion world flocks
to the international festival of fashion
in a year France their focus is on 10
finalists who this year include young
German designers at kostina born and
unborn heart as well as Anna Lee Shubert
who studied in Germany the competition
is their big chance I have no
expectations it's about the experience
being with the people here enjoying the
atmosphere and exchanging ideas and
that's really great
the international festival of fashion
and photography which takes place at the
villa Noi is a mixture of fashion show
industry gathering a conference and
exhibition for three decades it's been
drawing designers artists and
fashionistas to the small French town of
a year celebrities make up the jury
among them this time Princess Caroline
of Monaco
Chanel's creative studio director
Virginie BIA and model Kevin Linda
mercury I think we made a very eclectic
10 finalists they're very different
propositions and I'm quite proud I'm
quite proud but there's some very
interesting things I think our vision
altogether would be to choose someone
that has a vision of a woman who can
create something invent something that's
the advantage of being in a year far
from the fashion circus here budding
designers get to mingle with industry
greats in an informal setting was fear
is quite relaxed you can talk to people
and make contact which is quite pleasant
that awful feeling of distance is gone
villain hoy has been promoting such
dialogue since the mid 1920s back then
the villas owners shall and loving law
no I invited artists and designers to
come and influence one another's work
jean-pierre blonde revived the idea when
he founded the festival in 1986 my first
idea was to improve the relation between
young designer and and professional
people because I'm thinking that it is
too much clothes and I would like to
open it that's a really the reason at
the beginning something something like a
dream the festival isn't only about
fashion and photography French neo
focusing a woodkid also put in a
surprise appearance just fashion for
fashion doesn't really mean much fashion
is made you have people wear them and
use them in a context so everyday life
videos movies and stage music backstage
the tension is building most of the 10
finalists have just completed degrees in
fashion design in about half an hour
they'll present their creations at the
final or deciding Fashion Show held an
a-bomb they were see site some 900
guests are expected
the designers examine each piece one
last time you just want to check that
everything's clean and well prepared I'm
getting rid of a bit of lint on my
creations which helps calm my nerves
each designer has created eight
different looks soon comes the moment
they've all been waiting for the
announcement of the four price winners
the festival's grand prize is worth
fifteen thousand euros Anna Lee Shubert
took her inspiration from classic aprons
apparently the judges liked it the 28th
roll designer won the premiere vision
grand prize Anna borne Holt also has
something to be happy about she's won
the Chloe price sponsored by a French
fashion house I think this is going to
sink in only later when the jury met
this morning it was clear that she would
be the winner
we were all so taken with the way she
presented herself as a person
even those who didn't take comprises had
cause to celebrate
I've just been selected to take part in
the air festival has made them known to
fashion experts the world over